Kylie Jenner and Travis Scott know how
to co-parent like a boss the former
couple may have called it quits earlier
this month but that didn't stop them
from enjoying some fall family fun with
their one-year-old daughter that's right
et has exclusively learned that Kylie
Travis and stormy joined Kylie's sister
Courtney and two of courts kiddos rein
and Penelope on Thursday night at night
of the Jack and Qing galette ranch in
Calabasas now a source tells et that
both Kylie and Travis worked together to
focus on their daughter during the
Halloween outing noting that they were
quote such a great team they were very
involved with stormy they took turns
pushing her around the ranch in a pink
Ariel themed stroller
they were extremely attentive and had
their eyes on her at all times
[Music]
the fam hung out for over an hour and
according to ET source everyone was
really feeling the spooky spirit rockin
scary masks and checking out all those
hand carved pumpkins including one that
featured another Kardashian sister the
source tells ET quote at one point
Kourtney and Kylie had a fun sisterly
moment on the trail and took a photo of
Kim and Kanye's jack-o'-lanterns
but the amicable outing really isn't all
that surprising given that a source
previously told ET that the duo is quote
great at co-parenting Kylie and Travis
are both young but they are very mature
and have been handling parenting post
breakup really well Kylie and Travis
don't want any drama and are on the same
page of keeping stormy happy and she's
had her big sisters Khloe and Kourtney
to look up to when it comes to learning
how to co-parent
when Ichi caught up with courts ex Scott
Disick and Khloe in June they opened up
about the hard work it takes I think you
just gotta figure out really what's
important to you at the end of the day
life is a challenge and if you work at
what you want you can get it but it
takes hard work simple as that you can
easily live less of a life without
working as hard well it looks like the
hard work is paying off because stormy
couldn't be sweeter on Thursday after
this moment from Kylie's office tour
went viral
Kylie shared this video of her baby girl
dancing to a remix of her singing rise
and shine
mommy singing oh you want daddy singing
I'm not good enough okay okay and if
that weren't cute enough
Kylie captioned the clip daddy's girl
well that's just the cutest thing I've
seen all week and of course you can
count on et to bring you all of Stormies
a cutest moment so make sure to keep it
locked right here until next time I'm
Hallie Stephens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
you